like all versions of Fire Emblem fates  conquest is a turn-based strategy game  but it's the most difficult version of  the bunch because you don't have the  option to grind for experience and  strengthen your troops the wave Fire  Emblem fates intertwines relationship  building with combat is its defining  characteristic and it works so well  because it's two halves balance each  other out but your ability to explore  these pursuits is woefully limited on  purpose and conquest  the omission of grinding made playing  conquest all the more difficult but more  importantly it robbed me of gameplay  that's readily available any other  versions of the game disappointed as I  was I still enjoyed my time with  conquest but when I was backed into a  corner after a series of hard fights  with no resolution but to lower the  difficulty i wish i was playing  birthright instead